>>> ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME BACK TO CNN'S SPECIAL
LI COVERAGE.
I'M JOHN BERMAN IN LVIV IN
WESTERN UKRAINE.
BEHIND ME, IT'S ABOUT 6:30 AT
NIGHT HERE, YOU CAN SEE THE
SMOKE STILL RISING FROM BEHIND
THAT HILL.
A RUSSIAN MILITARY STRIKE ON
WHAT APPEARS TO BE A FUEL DEPOT,
A FUEL STORAGE AREA.
WE HEARD THREE BLASTS, AND NOW
CNN'S DON LEMON IS ON THE GROUND
THERE, ON THE SCENE.
DON, GIVE US A SENSE OF WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING.
>> WE ARE JUST TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION AS TO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING.
ACCORDING TO THE MAYOR AND THE
MILITARY MINISTER HERE, THEY
SAID IT WAS THREE STRIKES.
WE'RE BEING TOLD NOW AT LEAST
TWO MISSILES STRUCK LVIV ON
SATURDAY, REPORTS OF FIVE PEOPLE
INJURED.
THAT IS ACCORDING TO THE
GOVERNOR.
THE GOVERNOR ADDED THERE ARE
STILL THREATS OF MORE MISSILE
STRIKES AND SAID THAT HE'S
POSTING INFORMATION ON SOCIAL
MEDIA TO MAKE SURE, INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT WAS INVOLVED IN A
RESIDENTIAL BUILDING OR OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE OBJECT THAT WAS
NOT CONFIRM PREPONDERANCE OF THE
EVIDENCE BUT, AGAIN, THE FLAMES
ARE POURING OUT OF THIS
BUILDING.
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE SHOWING
UP, MORE EMERGENCY WORKERS AND
MEDIA.
BUT JUST TO SHOW YOU, THESE
FLAMES ARE STILL GOING.
AS YOU SAID, JOHN, RIGHTLY SO,
BEING FROM -- I GREW UP IN
LOUISIANA, AND THERE ARE FUEL
REFINERIES UP AND DOWN THE RIVER
CLOSE TO WHERE I LIVE, AND THERE
WERE FIRES, SADLY, THAT WOULD
HAPPEN OCCASIONALLY, AND IT
WOULD TAKE SOMETIMES DAYS FOR
THEM TO BURN OUT.
WHAT THEY WOULD DO IS HAVE --
THEY WOULD SET A CONTROL AND
JUST LET THE FIRES BURN OUT.
ENVIRONMENTALLY, IT'S NOT GOOD.
BUT IT'S THE BEST YOU CAN DO IN
THIS SITUATION.
BUT WHAT THEY'RE DOING NOW, I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE -- NOT IMAGINE,
I'M SURE WHAT THEY'RE DOING NOW
IS TRYING TO KEEP IT OFF OF THE
OTHER TANKS AND KEEP THIS FIRE
FROM SPREADING NOT ONLY FURTHER
INTO THAT FACILITY BUT INTO THIS
RESIDENTIAL NEIGHBORHOOD.
PETE, CAN YOU SEE THROUGH THERE?
SOME OF THE FIREFIGHTERS ON THE
SCENE THERE RIGHT TO THE RIGHT
OF THIS BUILDING JUST TO THE
CORNER OF THAT BUILDING.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE
FIREFIGHTERS ON THE SCENE AND
THEY'RE PUTTING A FIRE RETARDANT
ON THERE.
NO WATER ON THIS SITUATION.
NOT ON A CHEMICAL FIRE.
THEY'RE NOT USING WATER ON THAT.
JOHN, YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEING RELATIVELY SAFE, AS SAFE
AS YOU CAN BE IN A WAR, THIS
CITY FAR WEST FROM WHERE THE
ROCKETS AND THE BOMBS HAD BEEN
HAPPENING IN KYIV AND KHERSON
AND IN THE EASTERN DONBAS AREA.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST
CITY WEST OF THAT, AND IT WAS
THOUGHT TO BE SAFE.
BUT I AM SURPRISED, AS YOU ARE,
THAT THIS IS AS CLOSE TO
DOWNTOWN, THE CITY, AS IT IS.
YOU KNOW, AT FIRST WE WERE TOLD
WE THOUGHT IT WAS IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD A LITTLE FURTHER
AND THERE WAS A VALLEY AND WE
HAD TO TRAVEL SOME DISTANCE.
BUT WE HOPPED IN OUR VAN WITH
OUR SECURITY PEOPLE WITH OUR
TRANSLATORS AND WE WERE HERE IN
NO TIME.
THIS IS REALLY, REALLY CLOSE TO
DOWNTOWN LVIV.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS A
SIGNAL THEY'RE SENDING TO THE
PRESIDENT, SENDING TO NATO AND
THE ALLIES WHO ARE MEETING IN
POLAND WITH PRESIDENT BIDEN OR
IF THERE IS INDEED SOME SORT OF,
I DON'T KNOW, PRECISION
STRATEGY, SOMETHING AS TO WHY
THEY HIT THIS PARTICULAR
FACILITY.
BUT IT IS -- IT IS FRIGHTENING.
IT IS STRANGE.
AND THERE DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE